Hello, this is Michelle Hamburger. Welcome to another member's minute. I'm here with Dr. Connors.
Today we're going to be talking a little bit about dried fruit and other natural forms
of sugar and our glycemic index. We've had a number of questions come through from patients who are
being told or recommended that for their cancer they should be consuming x amount of fruit or
dried fruit. Specifically dates was one of the questions that we had received but there have been many
other dried fruit questions that we've received over the months and we are wanting to clear up a
few things about some maybe misconceptions about dried fruit and its benefit or its detriment and then
also explain a little bit more about how that correlates to our glycemic index. So I'll let Dr.
Connors take it from here. Well it's fruit a better substitute for a sweet tooth person
that eat a cookie with table sugar, right? Of course it is, right? Well fruit toast is still bad for
you so we should eat any fruit toast but fruit itself has other nutrients in it so if you're going to
eat some berries it has some good vitamins and minerals and other nutrients in it so that it
makes it a whole food for you. When you dry a fruit you do lose some of those nutrients through the
heat of dried fruit and you do retain all the fruit toast so when you're dried fruit you're basically
dehydrated and you're getting rid of the water, you're getting rid of some of the nutrients with that
but you are retaining all of the sugar so that becomes a problem. I would much rather have you eat a
whole blueberry than a dried blueberry but it can be a substitute, everything within reason,
everything within moderation but one of the things that we got to look at is what's called a glycemic
index. So the glycemic index of a food is an index on how fast it breaks down into glucose so
and that's really what we are interested in is because we don't want to be spiking our glucose levels
when we at any time whether we have cancer or not but certainly with cancer we don't want to be
spiking our glucose levels because glucose is a feeder of cancer and so even if you don't have
an extremely glycolytic tuber, you still don't want to be spiking our glucose levels too often.
So this is a chart and you can download one of these charts, you can certainly google it,
locate at the glycemic index of different foods, foods with a high glycemic index, you know,
one of the questions we had is somebody was told that they should eat dates because dates are good
for cancer patients. Well dates have some good minerals in it so I don't want to take that away from it
but dates have one of the worst glycemic index of any fruit, look at that, crazy huh? So cherries have
a lower glycemic index, pairs, apples because of the fiber content in it, also have a lower glycemic index.
All right, banana is up on that medium stage, orange juice, pretty worthless because there's really
not any nutrients in it, it has a fairly high glycemic index or it started to creep up into the
medium and into the high range here. Does it mean that you can't ever eat watermelon? No it doesn't,
does it mean you shouldn't eat watermelon every day? Maybe that would be a smart thing to stay away from.
But this is a good chart to look at and how fast they break down into glucose and it helps you
compare that. So looking at a glycemic index is a nice way to go for measuring your glucose
sugar consumption so you can see how fast here's an interesting point, here's white potatoes right
here, breaks down into glucose faster than eating blueberries does, interesting. So use this chart,
download one, look at your glycemic index, good hints on what foods you should eat and what foods
you might want to stay away from or at least live it. Before we end this, one of the concerns that I've
had, as I've heard many people talking about, well I'm not eating the refined sugar that I was
eating before so I can switch over to some of these natural sweeteners or natural fruits and
sources of sugar and that should be fine, right? But they're not necessarily reducing the overall
consumption of sugar because they're believing that it's coming from a more natural source. Like if
I'm eating, you know, dates all the time or I'm going to be eating corn. Just because dates are
natural versus a processed white sugar, it's still, it's going to break down to glucose. So you still
have to do your math and look at, you know, keeping that a balance because you might have to reduce
it, your total circulated glucose might just switch it to dates versus table sugar.
Okay, well thank you very much. See you next time.